let's go  I'm here live on Park Avenue and 56th  Street where it is complete chaos a man  in some sort of weaponized armored suit  is wreak havoc on Midtown everybody hold  your fire  check you got it wrong side of having  survived  we're boring huh did I scare you little  boy  [Music]  hey spider-man  I need come back yeah thanks for  stepping up for me you're the bravest  kid I've ever seen  I'm gonna take care of this - are you  gonna take care of your mom okay all  right there you go  [Applause]  you'll fight me you a fight huh I'm a  half of the five people in New York City  and real rhinos everywhere I ask you to  put your mechanized paws in the air I  just  so I hate you I decide y'all gonna come  down there you can kill me yes  I'll be right there there's no place  like home  [Music]  you  [Music]  you